if you choose to be the kind of artist
that stands for something that you want
to be yourself and bring yourself into
everything that you do you will get
fewer parts you will the parts you get
will move you in a way that most artists
will not get moved or you can bend and
manipulate yourself a little bit and
sort of be a little bit more of what
they want and play their role and even
though you don't really buy into it it's
a part and I want to be an actor I want
to be a performer I'm gonna I'm gonna do
what they want you will absolutely get
more parts without a doubt you will met
you will can arguably have a better
career but will you'll be profoundly
moved as an artist the odds are lower
it's not I can't say never it's just the
odds are lower it's not better or worse
it is simply the decision on how you
choose to manage or lead your own career
[Music]